[Musica]
oggi vi parlerò di seconda identità di
seconda identità di secondo io di
secondo me stesso cercherò di parlarvi
di questo a partire da che cosa
dall'impatto delle novità tecnologiche
che stanno cambiando totalmente la
nostra vita personale
la vita economica la vita politica
l'educazione i rapporti sociali i
rapporti interpersonali tutto che cos'è
la seconda identità non è mai esistita
prima
questa è la vera novità non abbiamo mai
avuto una seconda identità prima oggi se
io devo fare il vero paragone tra la mia
generazione è la generazione dei più
giovani dei ragazzi che oggi hanno 15 20
25 anni io penso che la vera differenza
sia proprio sull'impatto della
tecnologia negativa per me per noi siamo
molto più scarsi siete molto più smart
positiva per noi ogni stupidaggine che
facevamo non lasciava traccia da nessuna
parte
ogni stupidaggine che fate lascia
traccia potete perdere il posto di
lavoro perché avete postato una
stupidaggine senza nemmeno immaginarvi
le conseguenze che la cosa avrebbe avuto
perché quando io ho fatto i primi
colloqui di lavoro da ragazzo avevo la
mia faccia la mia parlantina tre righe
di uno scarno curriculum delle cose che
avevo fatto fino a quel momento niente
di più
potevo in fondo intortare il mio
interlocutore assai facilmente quando
voi parlerete con un vostro potenziale
datore di lavoro il vostro datore di
lavoro potrà guardare tutto di voi chi
siete perché oggi attraverso le novità
della tecnologia
abbiamo una seconda identità abbiamo un
altro noi stessi e tutta la nostra vita
è tracciata in modo totalmente diverso
da com'era prima
che cosa vuol dire allora una seconda
identità
beh intanto vuol dire questo vuol dire
che questo cioè il nostro telefono
mobile che abbiamo da tanti anni ormai
molti anni
ma da qualche anno a questa parte questo
telefono mobile è molto di più di quello
che era finora adesso qualche anno fa
potevamo in fondo definirlo una cosa
abbastanza neutra era come l'aria
condizionata
forse addirittura come un'automobile o
forse possiamo paragonarlo a qualunque
altro elettrodomestico che avevamo in
casa adesso questa è la seconda identità
è la mia seconda identità è la vostra
seconda identità il mobile che avete
nelle vostre tasche perché dico questo
perché qui dentro c'è tutto quello che
io sono tutte le persone con cui ho
parlato tutti i siti che ho visitato qui
dentro ci sono tutte le modalità per
capire chi sono seguito bene ho seguito
male dove sono un certo momento dove
sono stato veramente c'è tutto me stesso
tutto qui dentro
chi controlla questo controlla tutto
quello che io penso tutti i miei gusti
tanto che alle volte 1 vacui e vede che
lui ti conosce meglio di come ti conosci
te stesso e alla fine qui dentro c'è
tutto e questo tutto è impressionante
perché non c'è mai stato un luogo prima
dove fosse racchiusa la mia identità
la mia persona la mia persona ero io
prima di questo e adesso invece sono io
e poi c'è anche lui perché qui dentro in
sintesi è stoccato tutto me stesso ed è
fuori dal mio corpo e qualcuno ci può
entrare molto più di quanto qualcuno può
entrare nel mio nella mia persona nella
mia vera prima identità che cosa vuol
dire che qualcuno come entrare più
dentro è vuol dire che ormai questi
telefoni mobili qualche anno fa erano
europei molti avevano il nokia c'era una
certa tecnologia europea oggi non c'è
più
questi telefoni che abbiamo in tasca
sostanzialmente sono più americani o
coreani o cinesi
il che vuol dire che tutti i dati che
noi abbiamo sono stoccati lontano da
casa nostra e chi ha in mano
questi strumenti ha in mano anche la
nostra seconda identità nel futuro le
guerre non si combatteranno
secondo me per i motivi per cui si sono
combattuto in passato petrolio frontiere
credo che le guerre si combatteranno
soprattutto per capire chi userà
sfrutterà sarà proprietario di questi
dati perché alla fine con questi dati
effettivamente si potranno vincere
campagna elettorale si potranno
controllare i mercati si potranno avere
campagne di marketing efficaci si potrà
sapere cosa pensa la gente quali sono i
gusti della gente si potranno ricattare
azienda nazioni e persone
e allora la seconda identità il secondo
me stesso che diventa oggi la vera
questione sulla quale affrontare dal
punto di vista filosofico etico politico
democratico sociale le regole e il modo
col quale sarà il futuro
e questa seconda identità è qui dentro è
la tecnologia che governa la mia seconda
identità
noi europei abbiamo totalmente persa
telefonini che abbiamo in mano sono
americani o cinesi e coreani qualche
anno fa avevamo telefonini anche europei
oggi praticamente nemmeno più e abbiamo
perso la partita della tecnologia
i dati miei io sono sul telefonino
americano star hanno da qualche parte
per tino in california non so chi li può
sfruttare chi ne è proprietario chi li
gestisce
non lo so non ho francamente nessuna
fiducia nel fatto che chi può avere
accesso a quei dati possa avere nella
scelta tra a proteggere la mia identità
personale o fare profitti attraverso
questi dati possa facilmente essere
portato a scegliere la seconda delle
opzioni sono stati tanti casi già oggi
io mi ricordo cambridge analitiche
facebook con caso di una gravità senza
precedenti che è stato messo a tacere
non se ne parla quasi più ma fa capire
quali sono le potenziali derive di tutto
ciò e allora dicevo stati uniti asia e
noi europei che abbiamo perso la partita
e la tecnologia qui dentro
che cosa vuol dire vuol dire che gli
stati uniti su questi temi che approccio
hanno molto spesso quando pensiamo alla
questione della regolazione di queste
materia negli stati uniti abbiamo
evidente
l'impressione che li la competitività
dell'industria hi tech che deve vincere
la protezione della privacy o della
proprietà personale o del punto dei dati
personali sembra che venga molto dietro
almeno questa è l'impressione che io
francamente o a me non piace questo tipo
di approccio
ma se guardo all'asia all'altro tipo di
modello si guarda alla cina
l'impressione che ci sia un approccio
diverso un approccio quasi opposto
l'utilizzo di quei dati di quella
seconda identità per in una transizione
molto facile molto veloce entrare nella
prima identità nella persona che è
inviolabile dovrebbe essere inviolabile
ma tramite questo secondo identità ci
entri allo stato può avere l'interesse
attraverso questi dati a controllare chi
sono che gusti o quali sono i miei
comportamenti e qui si entra in uno dei
nodi fondamentali del futuro della vita
perché io credo che lo stato debba
essere molto netto nel sanzionare messe
sbaglio se rompe una regola che lo stato
ammesso ma io non penso che lo stato
debba intervenire a prescindere dal
fatto che io rompa regole la mia persona
è inviolabile
anche nella seconda identità che oggi e
stoccata nel mio telefonino
e allora se è cosi come riuscire a
vincere questa guerra questa guerra di
influenza su chi riuscirà a imporre
delle regole che proteggano la persona
rispetto all'invasività o alla corsa di
queste gigante di questi giganti
dell'industria hi tech
tornano di moda due paesi e due parole
molto dei modelli e tornano di moda due
parole molto debole che sono la politica
e l'unione europea perché la politica
europea perché è evidente che o è la
politica che regola tutto ciò oppure lo
farà il mercato oppure semplicemente lo
stato imporrà la sua volontà e io
francamente sono terrorizzato nella
pelle d'oca pensare che sia il mercato a
regolare tutto ciò
perché qui ne va di mezzo i diritti
della persona e della politica che deve
decidere la politica cioè noi non il
mercato non le aziende hi tech
credo che sia meglio anche per loro
avere delle regole da applicare e non
essere di fronte alla tentazione ma allo
stesso tempo c'è di mezzo l'unione
europea perché l'uno europea perché come
dicevo prima l'impressione che gli altri
giganti del mondo vadano su strade
diverse
noi europei che noi siamo svedesi
portoghesi italiani francesi tedeschi
abbiamo la stessa filosofia la filosofia
che ci porta a dire che la persona è
inviolabile e la stiamo traslando in una
transizione etica democratica filosofica
anche sulla seconda identità perché lì
c'è la mia persona
messa stoccata sintetizzata ma è la mia
persona ed è inviolabile
così come la mia prima persona e se ci
fossero in europa avessimo 28 break sit
come hanno fatto i britannici
immaginiamoci una dissoluzione ognuno
per conto suo non avremmo nessuna
capacità di imporre agli altri
questa filosofia che come accennavo
prima è veramente tipica nostra dei
nostri valori della nostra civiltà
giuridica
ecco perché l'europa unita oggi ha una
missione più è una missione diversa e
molto più impegnativa e più importante
anche delle vecchie missioni che li
abbiamo sempre dato è importante per la
pace è sempre stata importante per la
pace è sempre stata importante per
l'abbattimento delle frontiere per
trovare regole comuni di convivenza per
lo sviluppo per la rappresentanza
dell'europa nel mondo quindi in mezzo
c'è molto di più quindi mezzo c'è il
futuro delle nostre persone e non è
fantascienza
quando si parla di queste cose si sembra
che si stia parlando di fantascienza ma
io vorrei farvi riflettere sul fatto che
due anni fa sti discorsi bio stesso non
avrei mai fatti oggi secondo me sono la
chiave di tutto il cuore di tutto e
attenzione questo è la seconda identità
e il discorso sulla seconda identità
forse fra due anni
ci ritroveremo qui e sarei tentato di
fare magari non io che non ne capisco
niente di queste cose ma qualcun altro
di fare del discorso su un'altra seconda
identità che è l'intelligenza
artificiale che la macchina quello che
la macchina farà al mio posto un altro
secondo me stesso
quali sono le regole con cui agirà
questo secondo me stesso e credo che qui
capiamo che cosa vuol dire questa
evoluzione è fatto che anche qui la
politica per un verso deve decidere e
non deve essere il mercato non deve
essere nemmeno la tecnologia decidere e
allo stesso tempo l'unione europea deve
imporre e deve imporsi con le sue regole
di civiltà giuridica basate sul rispetto
della centralità dell'inviolabilità
della persona
in sintesi e in conclusione se tutto
quello che ho detto fino adesso ha un
senso è vero in questa transizione verso
un futuro iper tecnologico ha una
qualche logica allora la politica è
decisiva importante non possiamo
abbandonarla così e l'unione europea è
decisiva importante l'unione europea
unita non randellata ognuno per conto
suo
l'unione europea unita io penso al mio
futuro penso al futuro dei miei figli ma
io credo che ognuno di noi faccia lo
stesso ragionato possa fare lo stesso
ragionamento non voglio un futuro in cui
devo essere costretto a scegliere se
essere una colonia americana o una
colonia cinese non mi piace mi piacciono
gli americani mi piacciono i cinesi ma
io voglio essere italiano e voglio
essere europeo
non voglio avere la scelta tra essere
una colonia americana cinese voglio
avere la possibilità di sviluppare i
miei valori i valori centrati sul
rispetto totale dell'inviolabilità della
persona per me vuol dire essere italiano
e adesso europeo e soltanto con una
politica forte e un unione europea unita
e altrettanto forte
si potranno affrontare questi temi e
potremmo essere potrò essere potremmo
tutti riflettere sul fatto che giunge
l'abilità della persona per noi è il
centro di tutto